hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar CTS essential 8 medium
transition your PSC research to the
clinic with confidence I'm Alexis Krause
of labyrinth
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher comm now let's get started
before you begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send well answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speakers Lawrence and Jen REO Sant
scientists research and development cell
biology Thermo Fisher Scientific and
joanna as per product managers cell
biology life sciences solution group
Thermo Fisher Scientific for complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen Lauren and Joanna you may now
begin your presentation
good morning or good afternoon everyone
depending on where in the globe you are
thank you for joining us on this webinar
my name is Johanna asper product manager
for pluripotent stem cell culture and as
mentioned earlier with me today is our
scientist from research and development
or in Camden REO today we will talk
about further potent stem cell based
cell therapy
more specifically looking at how you can
support work in this area with a variety
of cell therapy systems or cts products
most recently and most notably DDS
essentially eight medium
I'm sure you are well aware that third
potent stem cells our PSCs hold
tremendous potential for cell therapy
with their ability to soften you and
differentiate into many cell types of
the body according to this reference
many researchers around the world
recognized that and are working to
realize that potential through various
clinical studies using IPS ES and
perhaps you are already involved in one
of these studies or perhaps you aspire
towards joining these ranks and in any
case I hope that today's presentation
will help you realize the potential of
pscs in therapy
for my section I will talk about cell
therapy some considerations in choosing
reagents and how we can help I will
briefly introduce the give Co essential
8 media system and go on to describe how
C D s essentially medium is based on
essential 8 but it is more appropriate
for cell therapy i will then introduce
and assemble the compatible products in
a workflow that gives you the best
support for your PSC based cell
therapies and just a quick note in her
section Lauren will show you the the
data relevant items number 3 and 4
with that out of the way my first point
is the single most important point that
I would like you to remember from this
talk when you think of cell therapy
reagents are no longer just your agents
when you're doing clinical research or
even when you're doing translational
work planning out what will eventually
be used in clinical research and beyond
you have to think about your agents in
terms of how they would touch or
influence a therapeutic product as such
in a cell therapy mindset reagents
become ancillary materials how are they
different ancillary materials are
materials used in the manufacturing
process but are not intended to remain
in the final product
and this includes things like Culture
Media although they're not present in
the final product they are essentially
your raw materials in fact that's how
ancillary materials are referred to in
Europe so all the things you think about
when it comes to raw materials you do
have to consider here is it safe enough
is it pure enough it matters because
materials used during processing could
influence the performance of a final
product it also matters because it's
possible that some of this material
could still end up in the finished
product even if you don't need for it to
because ancillary materials are
to go to the quality of performance of
the performance of cell therapies there
are many direct and indirect regulatory
guidance 'as on the choice or use of
ancillary materials and here you just
see the main regulatory guidance
documents across the different regions
we are not going to go through each of
them but the point here is that reagents
in cell therapy do need to be reviewed
with different lenses than in basic
research they are regulatory lenses and
it may be slightly different lens even
depending on your strategy for example
where do you intend on developing or
commercializing a therapy
so the materials you use are considered
as reagents raw materials ancillary
materials with that in mind what do you
consider when choosing what to use first
and foremost of course you want a high
quality product that performs well next
because this is a raw material used to
generate therapies of course you want it
to perform consistently next thinking
about a raw material more practically
you want to make sure that you have a
stable reliable supply that supports the
continuity of your work not only that
but also you want to make sure that your
supplier is able to accommodate your
increased need for that material once
you scale up for clinical trials and
beyond next as an answer there ancillary
material that touches the cells that
eventually become a therapy you want it
to be as safe as it can possibly be and
very much related to that you want it to
comply with the relevant regulations
next and this is not something that
we've touched on yet but you want to
make sure that you actually have rights
to use the material for commercial
purposes and not all products grant that
and yet that is most likely what you
will need if you were to bring your PSU
work to the clinic and finally if you're
not using the exact same reagent from
start up development to the end then you
should consider our agent or a set of
reagents that give you a clear path from
bench to the clinic and we'll talk about
that a little bit more later but clearly
there is a lot to think about when
choosing ancillary materials and many of
these considerations are not as simple
as we'd like them to be as you saw with
just the variety of regulations to
consider and moreover at the
translational stage many of these might
feel like distant concerns and it would
be tempting to really just you know put
off thinking about them at all however
the earlier you think about it the
better because you can choose the right
reagent during development and have a
smooth back to the clinic in the
alternative non ideal scenario you might
develop the therapy with one reagent and
prepare for a regulatory filing
years after to find that the supplier
can't accommodate your increased volume
or you don't have commercial rights or
there are regulatory concerns with your
choice
maybe formulation is not appropriate for
cell therapy or the QC testing is
lacking or documentation is lacking in
any case you'd have to account for the
extra effort and cost either rectifying
the issues with the current reagent if
that's even possible or switching to a
more suitable reagent and all the
redevelopment and comparability studies
that that might entail again not the
ideal situation but the good news here
is that we can help you with a number of
the considerations upfront
on the first point we have over 30 years
of experience manufacturing products
under cGMP our current good
manufacturing practices this is true
across multiple manufacturing sites and
across a wide variety of products
including most of our research use only
or are you old media along with our cell
therapy systems or cts products what
that means is that our manufacturing
sites are registered with the FDA and
are certified to certain ISO standards
the rigorous practices we adhere do at
these sites ensure the consistency
reliability and high quality of a wide
variety of PSC workflow reagents I'd
like to point out as an example all
Gimpo PSC culture media whether are
you--oh or CVS are GMP manufactured
on the second point the same along
history experienced in that scale across
multiple sites enables us to provide you
with reliable supply and to continue
supporting you even as you scale
yourself scale up your own operations
now again up to this point since this
has to do with our company and our sites
in general this is true for both ru
oncbs products as we continue down the
list of how we can help you you'll start
to see more of the differences between
our UO and CTS products and why CTS
products provide the best support for
cell therapy needs
we'll start with safety
CTS products are specifically intended
for cell therapy and the such undergo
extensive safety testing at QC and all
set safety testing as well as raw
material information pertinent to safety
can be found in our certificate of
analysis and certificate of origin
next regulatory compliance we have
experienced technical quality and
regulatory teams to help us understand
the direct and indirect regulations as I
mentioned earlier they help us design
our CTS products so that we can minimize
regulatory risks and aim to satisfy our
regulatory requirements they also
collect and curate regulatory and
traceability information that can be
very challenging to do and then they
funnel this information into a more
readily available set of documents such
as our certificate of origin and often
also drug master files to facilitate
your regulatory filings finally the same
experts become resources that do provide
CGS customers with with support to avoid
pitfalls in their path to the clinic
next commercial use rights we provide
guidance and support for the commercial
use of CTS products in fact CES products
typically carry the intended Restatement
for research use or manufacturing of
cell gene or tissue based products
you
finally we have seamless transition we
understand that you may start your
research with quite sensibly a research
use product what we have RCDs products
that have the same or similar
formulations as our are you own products
except making the formulations Eno free
or animal origin free the reduced risk
and variability as such you can start
with the ru o product and know that when
the right time comes you can easily
switch to a CTS version
so these are different ways that we can
help and in fact we have helped quite a
bit
our products have been used in more than
a hundred seven genes gene therapy
clinical trials to date and beyond that
several of our products are used as
critical raw materials and
commercialized cell and gene therapy
manufacturing so you can trust us to be
your partner in bringing your own PSC
base therapy to the clinic
now let me switch gears here to
specifically talk about the essential
media system and how we can help you
here
accentuate medium is a feeder free and
zeno free PSC medium that uses the
Thompson Labs v8 formulation the medium
kit is comprised of a basal medium and a
supplement but it's named essential 8
because altogether it contains only
eight components that are critical for
growing pcs this is the key reason that
many researchers have adopted
essentially medium eight components
means less sources of variability
compared to other media that typically
have a lot more components eight
components also means that it is more
cost effective and therefore more
scalable than other more complex media
and again like all gecko PSC media
essential 8 is GMP manufactured
for a clearer view of what I meant in
the previous slide the table on the Left
shows a comparison of a more traditional
medium and teaser versus the eight
essential components in this media
system there's a clear difference in the
number of components of course and I
stated below in the quote because it is
so simple it can be made in in a more
controlled way but one striking
difference in the formulation is the
presence of BSA in empty xur and the
absence of either BSA or HSA in
essentially that's important because BSA
or HSA for that matter is animal origin
material and is a source of variability
as well as put a potential source of
adventitious agents so essential 8 with
the removal of BSA and the recommended
use of a defined animal origin free
substrate like liquor nekton provides a
good foundation for cell therapy grade
medium and it's not just because of the
formulation itself
helps that we know that it works really
well we know it supports classic PSE
morphology normal karyotype hi PSE
marker expression and tri lineage
potential over many many passages it's
been tested in well over a hundred lines
and at this point has been cited in over
600 different publications for a variety
of PSC applications
for a while now we have offered
different versions variations or
combinations in the essential aid family
of products always of course trying to
provide the product that is right for
our customers no matter what it is that
they're doing
apart from essential aid for PSC
maintenance and expansion there's
essentially flex with stabilized fgf2
activity for PSC maintenance with a
flexible feeding schedule or you can
combine either of those media with
provide the cell supplement for
stressful events like single cell
packaging and then there's a central six
medium which does not contain growth
factors and can serve as a great
baseball medium for differentiation or
other PSC applications
now expanding on a point I made earlier
being GMP manufacturers Ino free more
consistent and more cost-effective the
essential eight system has always lend
itself well to an eventual cell therapy
application but we knew that there were
opportunities to further tailor the
product for cell for cell therapy as
such we now introduce the newest
addition to the essential aid family GPS
essential medium this CTS version of
essentially medium was designed to meet
global health or the regulatory
requirements it reduces risks because it
is rigorously tested and is animal and
human origin free in fact right now it
is the only globally available animal
origin free PSE medium and then like the
rest of our CTS products it facilitates
regulatory filings with cGMP
manufacturing and regulatory
documentation finally it does enable a
seamless transition from the ru o
essentially medium because it uses the
same eight component formulation though
with animal origin for your AOS
components
going deeper into the differences in
terms of document date documentation PDS
essentially does have a drug master file
as I said it has a completely animal
origin tree formulation and won't have
full traceability information and
documentation on the various components
of that formulation
as for QC it does undergo the same
functional testing using h9 es es over
three passages
both have sterility testing CTS
essentially test really testing
according to USB it undergoes qPCR
mycoplasma testing and a stricter
endotoxin specs
I'd say what is evident in all of these
differences is that we did perform a
regulatory risk assessment when CPS
essential aid was being designed we
looked at the original essentially
medium evaluated it against global
regulatory requirements and that is what
drove the improvements in the
formulation the documentation and the QC
testing to fit cell therapies at the end
of it all we are able to provide a PSC
medium with e with a different infinity
statement that should again facilitate
your regulatory filing and that is for
research use or manufacturing of Celgene
or tissue based products
obviously a PSE medium is not used in a
vacuum it fits into a complete workflow
often stretching from somatic cell
culture to reprogramming to banking
differentiation and characterization as
you can see here we have a complete and
robust offering across the ru Oh
essential 8 workflow PDS essential 8
being very similar has a list of
compatible products and the workflow
that basically mirrors this while
incorporating c.d.s products that would
better support cell therapy and then
altogether what you would see is a
seamless transition in the PSC work so
from ru Oda CTS and we'll go through
this step-by-step
so if you're starting with fibroblasts
for the standard fibroblast culture
medium contains FBS and we do have GMP
manufactured FBS as well as GMP
manufactured knockout serum replacement
as you might expect serum replacement is
more defined and this one is more
specifically used for PSC related
applications though more for feeder
dependent PSC culture differentiation
with further supplementation it can be
used for culturing fibroblasts pre
reprogramming of course for cell therapy
purposes we would recommend using CTS
knockout serum replacement XS which is
based on that widely cited ru o product
just the difference would be that this
is Zeno free and like other CGS products
it has more extensive testing and has
documentation to support regulatory
submissions
for the reprogramming step on the are
you--oh side we have the site achoo and
i PS 2.0 kit which has the highest
success rate among non integrating
reprogramming technologies for cell
therapy we do have a CBS version on CD s
sighted student IPS 2.1 kit it's a
really cool product it is the first
off-the-shelf reprogramming system
designed for clinical and translational
research what it does is it replaces C
make with L mix or weaker transformation
activity it has no BSA in the viral
dilution buffer and it's produced in a
GMP certified facility for consistency
of the material unlike the previous EDS
product it undergoes extensive testing
and has the documentation to support
your regulatory submission
in terms of PSC culture
yes essentially medium it is compatible
with give covet Renekton which is the
defined matrix that the Thompson lab
designed for use with a central 8 system
it's also compatible with give
programming and 5 to 1 which is also
designed what would be a more robust
option and it's great for challenging
applications of course were the best
option for cell therapy we do have CTS
vit Remington and that uses the same VPN
and variant that has been shown to
support the attachment and survival of
PSE s better than wild-type it Renekton
at this point I'm sure you're spotting
the trends it has extensive testing and
documentation
in terms of passages in the CTS
essentially system we primarily
recommend non-enzymatic passages with
our GMP manufactured Burstein solution
if you are at a stage where you need to
use a CTS product or want to do
single-cell passages you can use CTS
triple select enzyme which has the same
formulation as the REO product but has
extensive testing and regulatory
documentation if you do perform single
cell packaging with cts e8 just like
with essential 8 please do make sure to
use a Rock inhibitor we particularly
recommend our GMP manufactured your
vital provide a cell supplement
for cryopreservation RZ no free and GNP
manufactured PSE cryopreservation kit
provides the best performance as it was
optimized for PCs for a great animal
origin free option with the usual CTS
benefits we do have CTS cyntha freeze
medium if you use cdsmp freeze
we also recommend using the right SL
supplement post ball for optimal
recovery
now I won't go into the details of
differentiation since protocols and cell
types of interest vary widely but we do
have a wide variety of basal media
theorem replacement supplements and
growth factors under the CGS brand they
all have our you old versions and they
all have the same or similar formulation
but offers the extensive testing and
regulatory documentation that I've
mentioned with the others as well
so those products and recommendations
are summarized here and this is the CPS
essential eight workflow looking quickly
at the characterizations
pscs have traditionally used cellular
methods to look at PSC marker expression
fairly new attention after after the
reprogramming process after extended
culture number gene editing for example
these cellular methods are mostly Amina
staining but you can also do flow
cytometry but they're very qualitative
or semi-quantitative except when you go
into that flow cytometry level we do
have antibody kits that facilitate these
kinds of characterizations however
molecular methods enable more
comprehensive characterization in a more
standardized and scalable fashion these
are very important characteristics when
thinking about cell therapy therefore
along with the use of cts products if
you are going to cell therapy we
recommend characterization with the
pleura test essay for pluripotency
confirmation the type of man HP SC score
card panels for travelin trailing edge
potential and the carries that assay for
assessing genomic stability in lieu of G
banding which you'll hear more about
when Lauren starts her section
so let me close my section with a
reminder of four key points first with
technical and regulatory expertise cGMP
compliant manufacturing sites in a broad
portfolio of cell therapy systems
products
Thermo Fisher Scientific is a trusted
partner in cell therapy second essential
a medium is a widely cited Feder free
PSE medium favored for its minimal and
defined
xeno free formulation drawing from that
we have my third point CGS essential
eight medium enables the seamless
transition to the clinic with an animal
origin free formulation extensive
testing and regulatory documentation and
lastly combining essential Aid and CVS
essential eight with the other products
in the workflow thermo Fisher offers a
complete and compatible set of ru o and
CTS products to support your PSC
workflow from bench to the clinic and
now I'm going to hand you over to Lauren
to go over the application data
okay in the second half of our
presentation I'd like to share some
application data for CTF d8
first we'll look at data comparing
research use and CTS c8 and all outline
how you can transition your cultures
between these two media next we'll look
at long-term PFC culture and then
finally we'll talk about scaling your
PFC s and also reprogramming with PTSD
eight
as Joanna mentioned earlier in the
presentation CTS PA contains the same
eight components as research ECT 8 but
PTSD 8 has all animal origin three
versions of these components so to be
sure that there are no differences in
performance between these two media we
cultured pfcs for a number of bursting
quant passages in both the research
youths and in CGS eh and then we looked
at some typical PFC characteristics
and then images on the left panel of
this slide you can see representative
PFC morphology for each media the pscs
here have the typical attributes that
you'd look for the cells are tightly
packed the colony edges are smooth and
they have high nucleus to cytoplasm
ratio in the right panel we monitored
from fluency over time for psu cultured
in both media as you can see the growth
curves are comparable for research use
and PTSD age
so in terms of morphology and growth
kinetics both of these media performed
similarly
next let's look at meeting this proposal
see for the two media for these studies
PFCs were cultured in both media for 20
passages and then assay for pluripotency
using two different methods
the left panel shows results of
quantitative ICC analysis
for both media there is a high there is
high expression of certain sea markers
opt for nanog and socks too
the right panel shows the results of
pleurotus
which is an array based assay that
quantifies global gene expression it
includes markers found and pour potent
and noms we're put in cell type
the plot PSP is cultured and research
use and CTS see a cluster close to one
another and are within the Red Cloud
which is associated with pluripotent
cells
the final PFC characteristics that we
have compared between the media is
Charlie age differentiation potential
for this study PSPs were cultured in
both media for 20 passages and then
embroid bodies were generated from the
cultures using essential six
the EDS were allowed to spontaneously
differentiate for 14 days and then we
collected them and asked they then using
the pacman hpsp scorecard a little about
scorecard it's a Q PCR based assay that
is based on a reference panel of genes
and it includes markers for self renewal
as well as ectoderm musa german endoderm
the top left panel on the slide shows
scorecard results for undifferentiated
PSCs
that were also collected at p 20
the pluses minuses here show that these
PFCs are able to self renew and are not
biased towards any of the lineages
there on the bottom left panel on there
our scorecard results for the EBS which
are negative for the self-renewal
markers and positive for all three try
lineage markers as expected the
scorecard assay analyzes a number of
genes on and one of the outputs is an
algorithm score which is shown in the
plot on the right
the takeaway here is that
undifferentiated PSCs cultured in the
two media has very similar algorithm
scores and the same is true of the EBS
for both media this implies that
comparable this implies comparable of
performance in terms of self-renewal
capability for the undifferentiated
cells and Charlie huge potential for the
e B's
so the protocol for transitioning your
PFC is that this BPA is very simple you
can take your frozen PSCs that you've
previously cultured in research you see
eight and then just follow them directly
into CTS z8 or alternately you can take
the cells take cells that you're
currently growing and research you see
eight and then passage them and just
recover them in CT SDH so as we've seen
a few slides comparing are either
research use and CTS d8 you can expect a
very seamless transition when you're
making the switch between these two
media
you
next I'd like to share some data showing
on that PSD properties are maintained in
long term culture using cts e8 the ICC
images shown here on this slide show
maintenance of pluripotency markers ox4
SS CA for trial 1 to 60 and Sox 2 and
this is after 30 verse beam clump
passages in the CGS formulation
here we show that PSC's cultured
long-term maintain the ability to
spontaneously differentiate into all
three lineages
we culture the PFCs for 20 passages in
CTF c8 then generated EBS and essential
six through them and suspension for four
days and then plated them down and allow
them to spontaneously differentiate for
21 days
the ICC images here shows staining for
three lineage specific markers and this
demonstrates that PSC's cultures
long-term in CGS de maintain this tri
lineage differentiation potential
you
here on this slide we show further
evidence that the PFCs are able to
differentiate into three lineages after
long term culture and cts-v ate this
time with directed differentiation using
some of our gift code differentiation
kits
from left to right here we have ICC
staining for markers of definitive to
ended erm cardiomyocytes neural stem
cells
and dopaminergic neural progenitor
and lastly a common concern for stem
cell researchers is maintenance of
normal karyotype in long-term culture
here we show normal karyotype for PSCs
cultured for 20 versing clump passages
in CTS e8
the left panel shows normal karyotype by
G banding and the right panel shows the
results of curious stat analysis so a
little about curious stat it's an array
based assays that allows for digital
visualization of chromosomal aberrations
and it has a resolution that is similar
to G banding this curious stat plot has
chromosome number along the x axis and
then copy number on the y axis so when
you when your pscs have chromosome gains
or losses there's a spike in the blue
probe signal that would project above or
below the normal copy number range
however as this plot shows after 20
passages of CTS e8 we did not detect any
chromosomal aberrations via the scariest
assay
so the take way that I'd like to leave
you with here is that you can have
confidence when you culture pfcs long
term and cts e8 they'll be ready when
you're ready for your downstream cell
therapy applications
so in the next section we'll go through
a workflow for scaling up PS CS and CTS
BA
in this workflow POC for culture Don num
plastics with increasing surface area
started with a 60 centimeter square dish
and scaled all the way up to a to stack
milk cell factory system which is
actually a 20-fold increase in surface
area
for this expansion we recommend CTS to
Turnitin for your matrix and then see PS
triple sled for packaging so using this
combination of CTS EA and non plastics
we were able to scale up to 370 million
PS PS per two stack while also
maintaining normal morphology and
pluripotency
so in this final section we'll look at
reprogramming a fibroblast using CTS CA
this first slide shows a completely xeno
free workflow for reprogramming
fiberglass using the CTS Saida tune
reprogramming kit in the first part of
the protocol cells are plated and then
transduced in a Zeno free medium on a
collagen matrix the components for the
Zeno free media are shown in the blue
box and if you're interested in the
exact recipe it's available on our
website and the user guide for the CTS
site attune kit so it's a seven the
cells are harvested and replated on
either vit Renekton or laminate 521 and
the day after the medium is switched to
CTF v8 and after the switch emerging
emerging ntsc colonies are seen by day
twelve and are ready for transfer within
three to four weeks
our internal differentiation team to
fill up the Xena pre media that was
described on a previous slide and they
did this by screening a number of media
candidates are then choosing the
formulation that best supported
transduction efficiency fibroblast
growth rates as well as reprogramming
efficiency
they found that the sino free medium
also supports growth of primary
fibroblasts that are eyes that they
isolated from skin punch biopsy they use
this medium to culture and expand human
fibroblasts from two to three skin
pieces and the resulting fibroblasts
were found to have normal karyotype
an experiment shown here by robots to
reprogram using the cts sight attune kit
if you remember from the workflow slide
there is a media switch on day 8 to PSC
medium in this case medium was switched
to either research youths or cts 8 for
comparison purposes 18 days after
transduction reprogramming efficiency
which mess was measured by stating the
colonies with alkaline phosphatase
and as you can see from the plot
reprogramming efficiency is comparable
for both media
you
the team was also was able to derive
several new IPs see clones using the CPS
attitude kit with a CTS essential aid in
the next few slides I'll show how they
ask IVs clones to confirm pluripotency
differentiation potential and normal
karyotype the pleura test plot here
shows the new PI PSC clones clustered
within the red cloud which is associated
with certain cells
the team use scorecard analysis to
confirm that these clothes have the
potential to differentiate into all
three lineages
and then finally the parental fibroblast
and the new IPs see clones were found to
have a normal karyotype by both G
banding and bicurious
so in summary we've shown that the
transition from research used to CTS d8
is easy as a seamless and you can expect
comparability in terms of morphology
growth kinetics clear potency and tri
lineage differentiation potential
also PSCs cultured long-term and DTSC
eight mean takes maintain
characteristics of healthy PSPs
scalable PFC expansion can be achieved
by coupling cts CA with the nug cell
factory system
and finally cts-v a medium can be used
to reprogram fibroblasts in a completely
Zeno free workflow
okay now we'd like to open up for
questions
Thank You Lauren and Johanna for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on answer question box located on the
far left your screen and will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is why did you use triple
rather than four seen in the scale-up
experiment
okay yeah that's a great question um so
when you're passing with versine during
after your incubation step your move of
your seen solution but the cells remain
attached to the plate so in order to
remove the cells you'll need to flush
the media over the top of the on top of
basically over the top of the well and
that's really hard to do when you're
working with one of these cell factory
systems which is basically a multi-layer
multi-layered flask so when you're
chopped when you're passing the triple
select basically the cells come off the
surface of the plate into the into the
triple select solution and they're
easier to remove so that's basically why
we use triple select and diverse inset
ever seen it's also easier when you're
trying to count cells and see the
certain number of cells and shear into
your experiments and it's also helpful
when just to get you even more even
seating themselves across the flask
one thing I do want to mention is that
d8 is as we've been spoken about in
length ie 8 is a pretty lean media
system and so we do recommend versing
for just when you're doing general
culturing for long term culture it's
gentler and stencil generally liked to
be packaged as clumps so you can use
triple select for maybe two to three
passages as long as you're including a
rock inhibitor like Rytas or like or
vitae cell but we don't remember we
don't recommend long term pathogen with
a long term single cell packaging with
triple because it's stressful for the
cells and you might end up a carry
typical abnormalities so thanks for that
question
next question is now you you said that
you need to think about ancillary
materials as early as possible when do I
need to use CPS products
take that one so seems that they're
asking if you're using say for essential
a for example when would you need to
switch to CBS essential 8 all right
[Music]
that's a good question there isn't a
hard and fast rule to that like I
mentioned before the earlier the better
because you know that all or more of
your data pertains to their agent that
you will use for what will be the final
product if I had to draw a line in the
sand I would say that you would at least
want to do it when you create your
master bag you you might still be in
early development but when you create
your master Bank that master Bank is
where you will draw your final product
from even at the clinical stage whatever
you use in the master bank or to make
the bastard Bank will touch the cell
therapy product there for what you use
there is going to be under regulatory
scrutiny will actually influence the
safety and performance of your product
so based on that I would say that you
would want the best and safest and
cleanest most well-documented option
that you have at that point which would
be the CPS product so that's where I
would recommend it
now our next question is a two-part
question I'm interested in the Carius
test how do I use that
yeah do I need to have a microarray
I can take that one as well yeah sorry
we weren't too clear on that to all of
the molecular tests that we described
have free agents that you can purchase
and use in your own lab with compatible
equipment to analyze your samples so
qPCR machine for scorecard and then
microarray for pretest and curious that
we do recognize that not everyone has
access to these and we we offer these
services as well there's a website you
can go to to request service and your
account manager or your technical sales
specialist can assist you in getting
these services as well you think you
have anything to add to that Lauren no I
think you summed it up pretty well
Thanks
we are getting some great questions in
today so let's continue with a couple
more is there a protocol available for
the Zeno free programming
okay I can take that one yeah the
protocol is available on the thermo
Fisher web page for CTS site attune so
on you can find that protocol there it
also has some information for
reprogramming other cell types
I think PBMCs T cells 34 cd34 positive
cells one thing I note there is that the
protocol mentions only the research use
ee8 and that's because that product was
launched before we want we launched the
CTS e8 so we know that it's compatible
even though it does mention that
researching c8 and actually that is the
same for a lot of our product literature
and protocols at this point just
mentioning the research you see a but
based on our work with both media we
expect that CTS da can be used in the
same way as research you see eight for
the applications in our product
literature
I'm not using eh
okay I can take that one - that's a
really good question and unfortunately
we haven't tested we haven't really had
done much testing for transition from
other media systems to CT SDA
specifically but we have done a lot of
this testing for research use da so um
the thing to remember is that ei
infantry nekton is the lean media system
and it's also an AO f formulation so if
you're transitioning from a richer media
system that could contain animal origin
components especially BSA or HSA you are
probably going to want maybe an
intermediate step where you might
passage on a bit onto a bit of a richer
matrix such as over common at layman and
521 which we do offer and is all it is
in a web from any AOF product so if you
do that for the first few passage that
will help yourselves on that will help
yourselves why are you making the
transition so that's what we would
recommend there
I do want to add something there and
that is what we were to commend for the
best results we do also have published
protocols on our website for a
transition that doesn't involve laminin
but this is again still involving the
research use essential 8 medium you can
take a look at that as well it has
guidance on transitioning from from say
feeder dependent culture or rich or
medium and this would probably be as
well given the similar composition and
performance of essential 8 and CPS
essentially
and I think routing that and it looks
like we have time for one more question
can you tell us how we can get guidance
to avoid pitfalls when going to the
clinic and who do we contact I yeah I
think this might be referring to earlier
in the talk when I was talking about our
experts and how you have access to them
as resources so that's a very good
question
technical support is a valid way to
start and they're very accessible you
have their numbers available on the
internet depending on your question or
what you need support with they may have
the answer and if they if not they will
very easily pass it on to the experts
who can go into deeper kinds of
questions for our CGS customers the
other way you can reach us is through
your technical sales specialist who can
also answer some questions or pass it on
to the experts if it's something more
complicated in general I would say that
if you are interested in cell therapy
and especially if you're maybe at the
point where you think you might be
interested in CGS products even if you
don't have questions it's not a bad idea
to have a conversation with your
technical sales specialist so that
they're aware of your needs and they're
prepared to help you
Thank You Arne and Johanna do you have
any final comments for our audience
you
no further comments from me and yeah
yeah I just want to thank everyone for
joining us on this webinar
thank you again Lauren and Joanna for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through April of 2019 leverets will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be redirected to our upcoming
webinar cell and gene therapy solutions
enabling PSC translation workflows here
you will have the opportunity to
register for this live interactive
webinar as well as links to view past
webinars on demand until next time
goodbye